Herr weall vielleicht die erste Frage an
Sie wie würden sie den Umgang der
Bundesregierung in Sachen
Agrarsubventionen für die Bauern
beschreiben verbesserungsfähig
äh es ist es ist tatsächlich so es ist
vorer nicht geredet worden äh das
erklärt auch warum die Bauern im Grunde
wegen etwas anderem demonstriert haben
als man in Berlin gemeint hat es ging
nach meiner festen Überzeugung gar nicht
in erster Linie um den Agrardiesel
sondern es geht um eine sehr lange
Entwicklung ich möchte mein 20 Jahre wo
die Bauern den einock gewonnen hatten es
wird immer mehr von uns verlangt aber es
wird von der Gesellschaft aber es wird
nicht anerkannt dass wir eigentlich als
Teil eines großen internationalen
Marktes gar keine Chance haben darüber
ist nicht geredet worden da gibt's kein
Konzepten stattdessen gab es diese sehr
unvermittelten Entscheidung und das war
dann ja der Tropfen der rünen Fass zum
Überlaufen gebracht hat haben sie das
kommen sehen also wie oft haben sie da
gesessen in letzter Zeit und dachten wie
kann nur nee also bezogen auf die
Landwirte habe ich es tatsächlich nicht
kommen sehen weil das auch vorher nicht
absehbar war dass sie jetzt so
kurzfristig Teil von sparentscheidung
werden würden aber in Niedersachsen hat
man sehr viel Kontakt mit Landwirtschaft
und dass sich da etwas aufstaut ja das
war zu merken
und es ist ja tatsächlich auch so dass
wie gesagt immer auch Kommissionen
eingesetzt worden die haben auch kluge
Vorschläge gemacht nichts wurde
umgesetzt und irgendwann führt das eben
zu einer solchen Situation
die da man auch nicht auf Dauer anhalten
lassen auch sie hat man nicht angerufen
ja nein das war tatsächlich in einem
sehr engen Kreis sie sind doch FCH meine
mehr ich habe das gelernt jetzt in
Vorbereitung auf die Sendung mehr als
die Hälfte aller Deutschen Kartoffeln
kommen aus Niedersachsen ja und wir
haben auch die meisten Hühner möchte ich
mal annehmen die meisten Schweine obwohl
die deutlich weniger geworden sind und
so weiter ist wirklich ein starkes
Agrarland das also rauf und runter ist
Landwirtschaft mit der vorgelagerten der
nachgelagerten wirtschaffung in
Niedersachsen der zweitwichtigste
Wirschaft weig und das erklärt warum
mich dieses Thema sehr interessiert ja
noch mal warum ruft man sie da nicht an
ja das kann man sch das kann man schwer
beantworten wenn man nicht angerufen
wird
aber tatsächlich ist es so dass diese
Diskussion ja in einem ganz kleinen
Kreis geführt worden ist undter richtig
schwierigen Bedingung das will ich auch
ausdrücklich anerkennen aber das davor
sich in Berlin nicht herumgesprochen
hatte das ist bei den Bauern tatsächlich
ein Problem ist über das man reden muss
das ist sicherlich ja das ist ein Teil
des Problems und was fanden Sie
schlimmerusagen die angekündigte
Streichung oder die direkte Rücknahme
dieser angekündigten Streichungen nein
die teilweise Rücknahme der Streichung
die fand ich ausdrücklich richtig aber
auch da hätte es wirklich nicht
geschadet wenn man miteinander geredet
hätte vorher sie müssen sich das einfach
so aus Sicht eines Berufstandes
vorstellen der sowieso den Eindruck hat
mit uns wird eigentlich nicht geredet
und dann wird Ihnen zweimal ganz kurz
zweimal hintereinander das gewissermaßen
noch beispielhaft gezeigt ja ja und das
führt dann nicht zu einer Deeskalation
wie wir gesehen haben ich habe jetzt
allerdings den Eindruck dass unter
anderem durch das Gesprächsangebot der
ampelfraktion schon auch jetzt die
Grundlage dafür gelegt ist dass man
miteinander reden kann und wie sauer war
der SPD Kanzler dass der SPD
Ministerpräsident weil die Rücknahme
dieser subventionsstreichungenft das
müssten Sie Olaf Scholz Fragen ich hoffe
se haben sie seitdem mal mit ihm
telefoniert wir haben in der gemeinsamen
Sitzung sind wir gewesen aber wir haben
darüber jetzt nicht gerade
geredet zumal es auch klar da gibt's
eine Position des Bundeskanzlers die
nicht meine ist und umgekehrt das tut
mir leid ich möchte das tatsächlich auch
nicht zum Regelfall werden lassen ist es
aber mittlerweile ist das dritte Mal
jetzt na ja das mag sein ich zähle das
nicht aber ist tatsächlich so dass ja
ich glaube das geht gilt für mich und
das gilt aucht auch für meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja das ist noch
ein ganz anderer Fall können wir gleich
draf ich wollte nur was anderes sagen
das Ministerpräsidenten in erster Linie
die Aufgabe haben die Interessen der
Leute in ihrem Land zu vertreten glaube
das das gemeinsame Amtsverständnis dass
wir alle haben gar keine Frage trotzdem
noch mal ist das dritte Mal erstens
haben sie ih quasi erpresst mit anderen
mehr Geld für die Kommunen beim Thema
Asyl haben wir hier auch gesessen dann
haben Sie hier vpressst hab ich niemand
wir haben hart verhand hab ein
freundliches s sie wollten imm helfen ja
Geld los zu werden sagen wir so dann
haben Sie hier eine sehr aus Sicht der
kommun stellt sich das etwas anders da
weiß ich eine sehr harte Ansage in
Sachen industriestrompreis gemacht auch
da lagen sie komplett quer und jetzt
wieder ja das sind auch wichtige Fragen
wie findet der Kanzler das noch mal ist
das der Grund warum sie nicht minander
noch mal sie müssten äh das vielleicht
Inn direkt fragen nein ich habe den
eruck dass das persönlich das
persönliche Verhältnis da müssen Sie
sich keine Sorgen machen aber dass wir
in einer Situation sind wo wir wirklich
über wichtige Fragen auch reden und
diskutieren müssen und gelegentlich auch
unterschiedlicher Meinung sind äh das er
gibt sich einfach nur mal aus der Lage
man kann gar nicht drum rum reden wir
haben sowohl bei der Landwirtschaft als
auch bei der Industrie haben wir Themen
die sind richtig schwierig in der Tat
das Interessante ist ja dass nicht nur
sie nicht angerufen wurden sondern
offenbar auch der zuständige
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister nicht
angerufen wurde Jim özem mir sprach
parallel zum tagenden
Koalitionsausschuss im Bundestag und
sagte er wüsse davon gar nichts und im
Koalitionsausschuss müssen sich die
teilnehmen offenbar in die Augen geguckt
haben und gesagt haben oh unangenehm und
gehen wir mal raus und besönftigen
unsere Leute also sie war nicht der
einzige den man nicht kontaktiert hat
und wenn Ulf Scholz sie angerufen hätte
hätte er vielleicht auch gelernt so habe
ich das nämlich jetzt gelernt dass man
sich mit den Bauern auf keinen Fall
anlegen darf in der ertefreien
Zeit das so aber gut alles eine Frage
des Timings meinen sie das ist sch g
Timing das jetzt so dahin gesagt aber
tatsächlich reden mit Verbänden vorher
reden mit Minister den den eigenen
Ministerpräsidenten denn Herr WE war ja
nicht allein in seiner Ablehnung der
Regierungspläne sondern hatte eine
verlangst von SPD ministerpräsidentinnen
und Ministerpräsidenten an seiner Seite
und das ist ja ein Eindruck den man
gerne vermeiden wollen würde noch sie
fragen mün mal ist ein bisschen befangen
bei der Frage wie kommt das an beim SPD
Kanzler wenn ihm der SPD
Ministerpräsident öffentlich quasi in
den Rücken fällt na ich glaub da braucht
man nicht viel Vorstellungskraft das ist
natürlich das geg von gut und schön
gerade in dieser angespannten und
wirklich sehr zugespitzten Lage ich
glaube auch im Willi Brandhaus hat man
mal geschluckt aber auch da sitzt ja mit
lass klingball jemand der auch aus
Niedersachsen kommt der für die
Situation der Bauern auch in seinem
Wahlkreis viel Verständnis hat also die
Idee dass man sparen muss die wurde ja
in vielen nächtlichen
Sitzungen versucht einander beizubringen
dass man am Ende für ich glaub 400
Millionen waren es dann direkt auf so
ein Fass aufmacht dieses kommt ist schon
passt also schon höhere Politik im im
negativen Sinne aus meiner Sicht sag mal
so wenn der Kanzler doppelwums kann
können Sie dreifachwums jetzt der
doppelwums des Kanzlers hat eine andere
Wirkung als das wenn meine
meinungsbeiträge ist ja auch richtig ist
ja auch ein anderes Amt aber noch mal
wir würden einen Fehler wenn machen wenn
wir über bestimmte Fragen nicht mehr
diskutieren könnten ja das würde in in
Wirklichkeit nicht helfen und ich räume
ausdrücklich ein das war jetzt eine
sonders Situation nach dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts ein enormer
Druck auf dem Kessel richtig schwierig
alles konzidiert und trotzdem sieht man
am Beispiel der Bauern wir werden in
bestimmten Punkten um Kommunikation und
Diskussion nicht drum rumkommen und
dürfen wir auch nicht Herr Münkler der
der Politikwissenschaftler wie schaut
der darauf sie sagen das ist
regierungstechnisches Ungeschick man
könnte auch sagen
Dämlichkeit könnte man sicher auch sagen
nicht also handwerklich schlecht gemacht
das wurde ja teilweise schon ang
gesprochen die drei Vertreter der
Dreierkoalition sprech besprechen das
untereinander und suchen gewissermaßen
nach Punkten wo sie etwas kürzen können
und die Fachminister werden quasi nicht
zu Rate gezogen erster Punkt zweiter
Punkt sowas macht man nicht im Winter
sondern vielleicht im frühah oder im
Sommer ich glaube auch
äh dass man das Problem da bin ich ganz
nah noch mal bei Stefan
weil
nicht gründlich angegangen hat ist nicht
man hätte sozusagen schon eine Differenz
zwischen den kleinen Bauern und den
großen Bauern
herstellen können also technisch
gesprochen ähm ist das das schlechteste
was man machen kann eine Maßnahme die
gewissermaßen die doch sehr
diversifizierte Landwirtschaft und auch
noch Handwerker und
Transportgewerbe gewissermaßen in eine
Front des Widerstandes können Sie das
mal erklären sie ich habe das gelesen
von ihnen total interessanter Satz
natürlich hätte man versuchen müssen die
Kleinbauern gegen die Großbauern
auszuspielen es wäre technisch geschickt
gewesen warum na ja weil man
dann nicht alle gegen sich hat nicht und
man auch sagen können es gibt Betriebe
die haben tatsächlich fünf oder sechs
oder sieben riesige Traktoren und es
gibt welche die haben nur ganz kleine
Traktoren deren Sorgen und Probleme sind
auch sehr andere richtig und
wenn man Politik als eine Form das sich
behauptens unter schwierigen Bedingungen
unter mehreren herandrängenden
Herausforderungen begreift dann muss man
natürlich auch ein bisschen taktisch und
strategisch denken und das haben die
drei offenbar nicht gemacht
zugegebenermaßen Zeitdruck war alles
schwierig
ähm aber das war in jeder Hinsicht
eigentlich ungeschickt und es war auch
voraussehbar sie haben das jetzt mit
Herrn weil so diskutiert aber das
tendenziell alle Ministerpräsidenten und
Minister der Präsidentin unter dem Druck
anstehen der Landtagswahlen natürlich
ähm da nicht äh die äh den Rücken der
Ampelkoalition stärken werden sondern
auch darauf gucken äh wie habe ich eine
Chance mich bei der nächsten
Landtagswahl einigermaßen zu behaupten
mit einchuldigen Respekt es ist nicht
nur eine taktische Frage das habe ich
verstanden sie haben ja wir haben wir
haben bei uns ich glaube 35 000
landwirtschaftliche Betriebe ähm das ist
ein richtig wichtiger Bereich da geht es
um Menschen die arbeiten wirklich hart
und die sind in nicht wenigen Fällen
auch echt angekratzt durch das was sie
erlebt haben und da ist es glaube ich
gerade in der Demokratie wichtig wenn
man auch den Einruck vermittelt wir
verstehen was gerade bei euch los ist
und wenn man dann trotzdem Dinge machen
muss dann hat man eine andere Grundlage
als wenn sie gar nicht erst einmal
gelegt worden ist Tri dieses stadtland
Gefälle entschuldigung wenn ich das
sagen darf aber dieses ohnehin diesen
Frust über Berlin über die Stadt
ja die mir vorleb ich auf Land zu leben
me wir könnten stundenlang tagelang über
das Thema Wolf reden was ja nur ein ein
ein Synonym ist sozusagen für Probleme
die Städter und über eine
Landbevölkerung reden die Autos kaufen
soll die Sie vielleicht schon bestellt
hat
derungür wir mit einfachen Antworten von
extremistischen Parteien finde ich hat
das wirklich wie so ein prennglas noch
mal gezeigt das haben wir jetzt auch
erlebt in dieser Woche des Protest
erlebt bei dem war es nun ein
stürmungsversuch oder nicht aber ja
schlimmen Auswüchsen gingen die Fähre wo
Robert habck mit seiner Familie drauf
war will nicht sagen dass die Politik
das hätte vorausahnen und damit
verhindern können aber dass man mal
überlegt 49 € Ticket das ist schon etwas
super für die Städter hat auf dem Land
kaum Bedeutung es gibt einfach nichts
was da fährt dass man das vorahnt was
uns eigentlich das ganze Jahr
beschäftigt hat das ist eigentlich
heizungsgesetz Riesenthema ganz schlecht
gemachtes regierungshandwerk Reloaded
und das finde ich ist dann bei einem
erfahrenen Politiker wie Olaf Scholz
interessant dass er die in diese Falle
tappt
erfrid Münkler sagt Christian Lindner
erinnert mich immer an Charlie cheplin
warum na ja Charlie Chaplin packt mal
einen Koffer nicht und da guckt rechts
was raus und ein Hosenbein und ein Ärmel
und dann schneidet er das ab nicht und
das ist sozusagen in mancher Hinsicht
die lindnische Lösung und
wen man dann einen Schritt weiter denkt
also das ist glaube ich in dem Film dann
nicht mehr präsent aber wenn er den
Koffer wieder aufmacht um seine Kleider
anzuziehen dann stellt er fest dass da
relativ viel kaputt gemacht worden ist
und genau diese Situation hat letzten
Endes der Bundesfinanzminister
hervorgerufen indem er Kürzungen
Streichungen in dem Bereich äh in Gang
gesetzt hat bei dem er nicht hingeschaut
hat und dass er auch noch operativ
schlecht gemacht hat apropos operativ
schlecht gemacht über Kommunikation
haben wir schon ein bisschen gesprochen
ein ein sozusagen einmaliger Vorgang das
eine eine also die Spitzen einer
Regierung sitzen zusammen beschließen
das und der zuständige
Landwirtschaftsminister
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister stellt
sich dann vorne hin und sagt hätte ich
nicht so gemacht also habe ich nichts
mit zu tun der Finanzminister Christian
Lindner sagt ein wenig später na gut man
hätte das nicht so machen müssen und das
ist jemand und das haben die en mal ein
bisschen zusammengeschnitten und ist
sehr interessant das zu hören Christian
Lindner ist jemand der sehr
unterschiedlich argumentiert je nachdem
wie es gerade nötig ist zwischen den
folgenden Sätzen liegen wenige Tage 6
januar und 15 Januar schauen Sie mal
gerade eine europäisch und national so
hoch subventionierte
Branche wird sich nicht jedes
konsolidierungsbeitrags erwähren K
können man kann nicht auf der einen
Seite von jetzt der gesenkten
Stromsteuer profitieren wollen man kann
nicht zusätzliche Fördermittel für den
stallumbau fordern und auf der anderen
Seite auch an alten Subventionen
festhalten wer neue Subventionen will
muss auch auf alte
verzichten jetzt ist die Gelegenheit
neue Perspektiven für nachhaltiges
Unternehmertum in der landwir zu
schaffen bei dieser Debatte haben sie
mich an ihrer Seite ich kann Ihnen heute
nicht mehr staatliche Hilfe Versprechen
aus dem
Bundeshaushalt aber wir können gemeinsam
dafür streiten dass sie wieder mehr
Freiheit und wieder mehr Vertrauen für
ihre Arbeit
erhalten ja das erste war ein perfektes
Beispiel wie man im ptiielosigkeit
demonstriert gegenüber den Betroffenen
und wenn das erstmal geschehen ist dann
darf man sich über die Reaktion beim
zweiten mal nicht so wirklich wundern es
ist tatsächlich so ich glaube es ist
diese Diskussion ist ganz entscheidend
davon geprägt wie Politik auf Nöte von
Leuten reagieren ob man das erstmal zur
Kenntnis nimmt oder ob man es abwimmelt
und Christian Lindner hat das sehr klar
beim dreiönigstreffen in die zweite
Richtung orientiert ist es faszinierend
also du sagst erst pass auf also diese
subventionsstreichungen die werden
selbstverständlich kommen und da gibt's
auch gar kein Vertun und wenige Tage
später redest du nicht mal von Kürzungen
sagst ich kann ih nicht mehr Hilfen
Versprechen von Kürzungen keine Rede
mehr na ja gut im ersten Fall spricht er
sozusagen vor seiner
Parteimitgliedschaft er spricht
gewissermaßen zu den Leuten die
Bürokratieabbau
und zentrale Lösung für Ihre Probleme
haben beim zweiten Mal steht er vor den
Bauern nicht und wenn er sagt nicht mehr
versprechen dann meint er wahrscheinlich
wir sind ja schon ein paar Schritte
zurückgegangen nicht und mehr geht's
aber nicht ähm hat aber einen ganz
anderen Grundton einen ganz anderen
grundduktus nun würde ich sagen im
Prinzip ist das das kleine einm ein
eines gewiften Politikers zu wissen wer
ist mein Auditorium was wollen die hören
äh was können sie hören und derlei mehr
das hat er gemacht nun wä das in
früheren Zeiten wo nicht jede Szene
mitgefilmt wird nicht und dann
gegeneinander gestellt wird
gibt's ja von Adenauer diesen berühmten
Spruch was interessiert mich mein dummes
Geschwätz von gestern nicht
diese Zeiten haben wir nicht mehr
sondern das kann hier jetzt
gegeneinander gestellt werden und dann
sieht man
gewissermaßen ein Maß von Flexibilität
das schon an Unglaubwürdigkeit grenzt
Flexibilität immerhin hat er sich
hingestellt also man muss es ja sagen
war das Mitglied der Bundesregierung
kurz vorher war waren die Bauern in
kotbus wo der Bundeskanzler war weil er
ein icewererk eingeweiht hat und da hat
er mit dem Präsidenten der dortigen
Bauernschaft gesprochen aber sich nicht
mit den Bauern irgendwie gezeigt die
wurden am Berg vorbeigeleitet also klar
schwieriger Auftritt will man nicht aber
ich noch einen zweiten Teil wenn sie es
interessiert also es gibt ja so ein es
gibt ja gibt ja so ein so ein weltweit
so eine weltweite Tendenz zu zu Serien
und wir hen noch ein weiteres Mal
Christian Linden aus derselben Abteilung
die gefährliche Situation in die mein
Kollege Robert habbeck gekommen ist war
völlig
inakzeptabel die Sachbeschädigungen auch
die angekündigten Blockaden sind
unverhältnismäßig
Landfriedensbruch
Nötigung
Sachbeschädigung das sind Fälle für den
Staatsanwalt lassen Sie sich nicht
unterwandern und
instrumentalisieren sie haben sich
verrant bitte kehren sie um die
klimakleber haben das Brandenburger Tor
beschmiert die Bauern haben das
Brandenburger Tor geehrt und das ist ein
Unterschied und deshalb erwarte ich von
der Politik und von den
Medien von allen die befürchtungenäer
haben sich
stattdessen vor der
linksextremistischen Unterwanderung der
klimakleber warnen und deren
Sachbeschädigungen und blkorden
verurteilen denn das ist gerechtfertigt
her weil sagte gerade sie ersparen uns
wirklich nichts hier heute Abend kann
ich nicht wer möchte als
erster ja schwierig hätte ich mir
gespart an seiner Stelle zumal die
klimakleber mit den Protesten überhaupt
nichts zu tun haben und
das ist unglaubwürdig und auch das
Brandenburger Tor beschmiert geehrt also
was er sagen will ist legitimer Protest
völlig okay das ist Demokratie wir reden
immer über den Untergang der Demokratie
wir sehen aber gerade Demonstrationen
gegen die Regierung super Demokratie
vielleicht hätte er das so formulieren
sollen Herr münler hat ja vorhin gesagt
jeder Politiker redet so wie das
Auditorium vor istau der ist auch ein
Gram Wahrheit dran aber die
Glaubwürdigkeit gewinnt man dadurch dass
man in der Lage ist im Kern dasselbe zu
sagen natürlich müssen wir uns
vermitteln den jew jeweiligen Menschen
die vor uns sitzen aber von der Sache
her darf es nicht das Gegenteil sein
weil dann geht's sofort auf die
Glaubwürdigkeit und Glaubwürdigkeit und
Vertrauen das sind die eigentlichen
Währungen in der Politik wen W wer die
verliert hat ein Problem Herr Münkler ja
ganz ganz ihre Auffassung nicht
sozusagen man muss einen Kern haben den
modifiziert man dann ein bisschen je
nach
Auditorium hier ist dieser Kern nicht
mehr erkennbar sondern löst sich
gewissermaßen auf in ja den jeweiligen
Zuhörern nach dem Mund
reden die Leute merken das ja auch ne
die merken das und ich will aber noch
auf einen Punkt kommen ich meine was
offenbar wenig bedacht worden ist ist
dass wenn man sich mit den Bauern
anlegt dass man dann in einer auf Wut
und Zorn trifft wie das vielleicht wenn
man sich mit den Verbrauchern anlegt
nicht der Fall ist Verbraucher haben
auch nicht die Möglichkeit in
vergleichbarerweise zu demonstrieren
weil die kein drecker haben mein sie
weil wenn man einen drecker dorthin
fährt der im Prinzip das Volumen von 20
Personen mindestens hat nicht dann macht
das was
her die Zahlen die sich da versammelt
haben jedenfalls le man die
Polizeiangaben zu gründe die waren jetzt
nicht erschütternd das passiert in
Berlin öfter mal aber die fahrze die
eingesetzt worden sind das ist schon was
ganz anderes ähm es ist schon
erstaunlich wie wenig die drei äh oder
wer auch immer dann letzten Endes diese
Entscheidung getroffen hat das nicht
bedacht hat aber das ist so interessant
dass Sie das sagen weil das worauf man
sich ja dann verständigte im Gespräch
mit den Fraktionschefs also nicht mit
der Regierung sondern mit den
Fraktionschefs sei ja unter anderem oder
sieht unter anderem Gespräche über eine
tierwohlabgabe vor die schon immer mal
gefordert wurde in verschiedenen
Kommission die die Verbraucher ich hab
das gelesen undte seid ihr denn von
Sinnen also wir hören immer von der SPD
vor allem und Respekt und auskommen wir
müssen an die kleinen Leute denken und
so weiter und dann lege ich Dinge um
neben den steigenden CO2 Preisen und so
weiter die dann wiederum jede Familie
jeder Mensch im Supermarkt erneut zahlt
das kann nicht die Idee sein wenn ich
andererseits subvensionen abbaue damit
der Steuer mehr Geld vom Steuerzahler im
stsseckel ankommt also irgendwo wo
stimmt es nicht und ich
glau so predulie ist nicht der überlegt
sich vielleicht doch die Verbraucher
haben erst die Möglichkeit bei der
nächsten Wahl sich nachhaltig zu weren
das ist ehrlich gesagt in dieser
Situation vielleicht kommt die viel
schneller als wir denken und aus dem
Europa die neuwah mein sie jetzt ja ich
glaube auch in dieser Hinsicht es ist
kein taktisches Problem in erster Linie
es gibt ja zur Frage wie soll es
weitergehen mit der Landwirtschaft
Kommission zwei Stück sch die get haben
und die haben sich echt viel Mühe
gegeben und man hat die Erfahrung
gemacht die legen kluge Empfehlung auf
den Tisch dann passiert nichts und das
wieder geschieht den Landwirten zum
wiederholten Male und dann haben die den
Eindruck also wir spielen hier keine
Rolle und das wird dann noch durch
solche Entscheidung untermalt und
deswegen ist es wirklich wenn wenn die
Lehre daraus gezogen wird aus dem was
wir erleben erlebt haben jetzt musssen
wir mal wirklich dem im mal dem Grunde
auf auf den Grund gehen wir müssen uns
anschauen was haben denn diese
Kommission empfohlen können wir dem
folgen oder nicht dann werden wir schon
gutes Stück weiter und es ist aus meiner
Sicht auch notwendig um überhaupt wieder
neues Vertrauen da aufzubauen also im
Moment ist das nicht so ganz
leicht und da ist was wieder gut zu
machen würde ich sagen wichtig wäre wir
haben gerade über Kommunikation
gesprochen ein soll man sagen ein ein
gutes ein richtiges ein empathisches
Wort des
Kanzlers es gab einen Versuch wir hören
mal kurz rein streit gehört zur
Demokratie und zwar genauso wie es
Helmut Schmidt gesagt hat eine
Demokratie in der nicht gestritten wird
ist keine doch fast 50 Jahre später
stehen wir vor einer Bewährungsprobe Wut
wird gezielt geschürt mit gigantischen
Reichweiten mache Extremisten auch über
die sozialen Medien jeden Kompromiss
verächtlich vergiften jede demokratische
Debatte wenn jede Subvention auf ewig
bestehen bleibt wenn wir alle zu 100%
auf unserem Standpunkt beharren wenn wir
alles so machen wie immer dann kommen
wir auch nicht
voran und es ist wichtig dass wir das
große Ganze nicht aus den Augen
verlieren gerade in so aufreibenden und
aufwühlenden Zeiten wie heute gilt es
Maß und Mitte zu halten das sollte allen
DemokratInnen und Demokraten ein
Anliegen sein Aufrufe zu Gewalt und
persönliche Bedrohung haben in unserer
Demokratie nichts verloren Galgen sind
keine Argumente politische sind keine
vollposten wenn Sie das Hören alles
richtig in der Sache im Prinzip würde
ich sagen alles richtig nicht aber es
ist sozusagen eine Vertauschung der
Rollen das ist eine Rede die vielleicht
der Bundespräsident halten könnte
oder das Wort zum Sonntag oder ähnliches
mehr der Kanzler der doch im Prinzip der
Kopf der operativen Politik
ist bei dem würde ich sagen ist es ein
Zeichen dafür dass er im Prinzip mit dem
Rücken an der Wand steht wenn er in
dieser Weise spricht und nicht sagen
kann was man macht und was man machen
wird und wo die Perspektiven sind nicht
sozusagen so auf die Leute zugehen und
reden und seid doch vernünftig und denkt
darüber nach dass nicht nur der Streit
zentral ist sondern das Ergebnis das
dabei herauskommen soll das ist alles
wahr aber es ist in der konkreten
Situation falsch ja es ist auch eine
Situation also Kanzleramt wie sie sagen
erinnert an eine Weihnachtsansprache ist
ein ein wöchentlicher videoodcast also
es macht er zu verschiedenen Themen in
dem Fall wo es aber ja um die direkte
Kommunikation
ginge wäre tatsächlich auch man kann
sich in Berlin wunderbar Journalisten
Fragen stellen man kann in
Fernsehsendungen gehen also er hat
unfassbar viele Möglichkeiten mit einem
Resonanzraum zu kommunizieren und das
tut er nicht stattdessen deswegen muss
ich lachen das ist interessant dass Sie
das sagen mit dem Bundespräsidenten der
wiederum hat in dieser Woche ein
Interview gegeben in sich hat der ja
normalerweise so über den Dingen schwebt
qua Amt das ist auch in der Verfassung
so vorgesehen ist das Staatsoberhaupt
der dann sagt in einem sehr großen
Interview sehr zentral am Anfang
zusammengefasst also regieren muss man
erklären kommunikation ist wichtig bei
Vorhaben die man operativ durchführen
will und man darf nicht dauernd nur
streiten und nur ein ein ein Bild des
der des ist es vermitteln und sozusagen
er hat den Kanzler der ja aus seiner
Parteienfamilie kommt Frank Walter
Steinmeier war Außenminister
Kanzleramtsminister der SPD damit
öffentlich gerügt das ist eher selten
und das ist ein Rollentausch den ich
interessant finde als Journalistin aber
nicht wirklich gut für diese Regierung
ich muss sagen ich ich kann das nicht
teilen erstmal sie hätten auch zum
dritten Mal noch mal Christian Lindner
präsentieren können nämlich bei seinem
Video im
Kuhstall ja würde ich sagen da sehe ich
lieber Olaf Scholz im Kanzleramt das ist
wesentlich authentischer zweitens alles
was er gesagt hat war ausdrücklich
richtig und auch ein Bundeskanzler muss
in der zugespitzten Situation
tatsächlich aus meiner Sicht auch sagen
so leute ihr habt ihr lebt in einem Land
kann das authentisch hier eigentlich äh
das ist jedenfalls kein Video sondern
ein Foto sonder ein Foto des Kanz die
können Sie von mir auch haufenweise
sehen diese Fotos die finde ich
eigentlich ziemlich authentisch warum
decken Sie Gummistiefel ab mit
Plastikfolie ich weiß ich bin sowieso
nicht der größte Freund des
Gummistiefels wenn ich sagen wenn ich
das sagen darf wenn ich auf Höfen bin
ziehe ich meine Wanderstiefel an das ist
eigentlich immer der richtige dressp ja
ist richtig ja Gummistiefel sind in der
Politik ja auch so ein bisschen die
Frage wer sie als erst rausholen Fr von
Geschwindigkeit nein aber schön dass Sie
das Bild haben wenn sie jetzt das andere
Video hätten W es noch interessanter
aber der springende Punkt ist für mich
ein Kanzler muss auch sagen können Leute
denk mal haltet mal kurz inne das ist
absolut richtig und dass man aber auch
den direkten Kontakt mit den Betroffenen
suchen muss ja das stimmt ähm und äh
dass man das anders dann anschließend
auch vermitteln kann was sozusagen bei
anderen los ist das die Grundlage dafür
dass man überhaupt in der Diskussion
Gespräch reinkommt mm ja man man fragt
sich es es geht gar nicht so sehr um den
Inhalt man fragt sich warum warum redet
eher so ich weiß dass Olaf Scholz ist
stimmt es dass bei ihnen sozusagen den
den fraktionsolaf gibt also den Mann der
sehr hemsärmlich in der Fraktion sitzt
und und sehr frei oder wenn er von
Friedrich März richtig angegangen wird
im Bundestag dann dann läuft Olaf Scholz
ja zu Hochform auf wenn der frei redet
dann ist das der Kanzler den ich mE
vorstellen ja nun hat aber auch nicht
jeder das darstellerische Talent von
einem Markus Lanz beispielsweise ja und
das ist auch nicht das wofür
Bundeskanzler in erster Linie bezahlt
werden dass man bei einem solchen Video
so ist wie man ist das kann ich aus eene
Erfahrung auch bestätigen ja aber auch
die Helmut schmidz wachsen nicht auf dem
Bäumen also in die gibt es vielleicht
einmal in 100 Jahren oder in 200 Jahren
und zu seiner Zeit war Helmut Schmidt
wesentlich angefochtener als er das
später gewesen ist also ich finde wir
sollten auch mal akzeptieren dass jemand
authentisch ist und das ist Olaf Scholz
aus meiner Sicht
allemal allerdings insgesamt die
Regierung hätte in diesem Fall deutlich
besser dran getan auch Kontakt mit
Betroffenen aufzunehmen und
ja zu signalisieren wir haben verstanden
warum ihr so auf der perne seid Herr
Münkler sagt Olaf Scholz ist ein
superpitiker für die zweite Reihe
ja das haben wir
off Mitglieder gemeint als sie sich
entscheiden durften wer ihr neuer
Vorsitzender werden soll und sie ihn
glaube ich auf den Platz 3 gestellt
haben sicherlich ein ein ein fleißiger
Mann eingearbeitet tüchtig und derlei
mehr aber einer ohne Charisma ohne die
Fähigkeit oder keine Lust das
ausführlich zu erklären warum das der
Fall istm und deswegen in einer solchen
Situation meine dass er vielleicht eine
Neujahrsansprache hält die ein bisschen
salbungsvoll ist da ist ja nichts
dagegen einzuwenden aber in dieser
Situation hätte er über Politik sprechen
müssen ähm und äh es gibt so eine
Neigung von Politikern in jüngster Zeit
ihre Rolle nicht zu begreifen nicht die
stellen sich dann hin und Warden vor
etwas ja das würde ich sagen das ist
eine Grenzüberschreitung da gehen sie in
den Bereich der Wissenschaftler und
public intellectuals und Journalisten
und was auch immer hinein sie haben das
wovor sie warnen was Sie sehen zu
bearbeiten operativ zu bearbeiten und
jetzt nicht sozusagen sich
herausschleichen aus dem Amt und
kommunikative pyeten zu drehen ich
wirklich anders dass ein Bundeskanzler
die Möglichkeit haben muss zu sagen ich
mache mir Sorgen dass hier gerade sehr
stark überdreht wird und der Hinweis
beispielsweise auf die Geigen der war ja
nicht unzutreffend das ist finde ich
nicht nur se ein gutes Recht sondern als
Bundeskanzler auch seine Pflicht darauf
aufmerksam zu machen wir haben ja ein
paar Regeln an die sind wir alle
miteinander gebunden also bei allem was
man in der Sache kritisieren mag ich
finde wir sollten es jetzt mit der
krittelei auch nicht zu hoch zu eng
sehen ja aber was das also der Ausdruck
dieses Videos ist doch so eine gewisse
Mangel der Empathie tut mir leid ich
finde ulaf Scholz ist ein Politiker der
ersten Reihe würde ich Ihnen
widersprechen er war Vizekanzler
Finanzminister der weiß was er tut auch
international das will ich überhaupt
also da kann man ihm auch keinen Vorwurf
machen international macht das besser
als national finde ich aber dieses
gerade in so aufgeheizten Debatten sich
hinzustellen und quasi das diese diese
also Merkel hat so eine Ansprache
gehalten als es um Corona nehmen sie es
ern es ist ernst nehmen sie es auch
ernst
jetzt sind wir an einem anderen Punkt
jetzt geht es um Kommunikation es geht
um das Gespräch mit Menschen es geht um
versprechen die er nicht gelöst hat die
AFD halbiert sich werden Sie sehen mache
ich
die migrationskrise Deutschland packt
Friedrich Merz im Kanzleramt kriege ich
in den Griff nichts ist passiert das
wissen Sie als Ministerpräsident auch
gut dass die Vereinbarung mit den
Ländern nicht eingehalten wurden am Tag
des haushaltsurteils aus karlsruh steht
er im Kanzleramt und sagt machen sich
keine Sorgen es wird sie nicht betreffen
ich weiß dass er beruhigen wollte er
wollte dass die Leute nicht panisch
werden dass ihre Rente nicht mehr kommt
morgen oder das bfolk nicht mehr fließt
völlig okay aber gar nicht zu
kommunizieren auch Probleme nicht zu
benennen und nicht zu sagen ich habe
auch Fehler gemacht jetzt kämpfe ich
aber für euch das ist schlecht und da
muss ich sagen verstehe ich ihn auch
nicht weil er kann reden wenn er
getriggert wird dann dann wird der
emotional mir fehlt auch so ein bisschen
dieses mensch Leute seid ihr wahnsinnig
wie könnt ihr denn den Robert da so
angehen aber irgendeine Art der direkten
Kommunikation mit Menschen und das kann
man ihm finde ich total vorwerfen noch
Einsatz als Journalist da eine da sitzen
drei Männer im Kanzleramt plus drei
andere in Raum weiter über Tage Robert
habeik sagt eine Reise nach Israel ab es
wird jeden Tag mit der Rolle der
Regierung gespielt dann heißt es auf
einmal es gibt im Kanzleramt sie haben
sich geeinigt jeder telefoniert geht hin
und dann sagen drei Leute 5 Minuten was
von abgelesenen Blättern das ist das ist
ein ein Eingeständnis das wir haben uns
irgendwie geeinigt wir wollen es uns
euch aber nicht sagen weil wir es nicht
genau wissen und genau das ist ja
passiert und das finde ich unterirdisch
mhm aber vielleicht können wir uns auch
drauf verständen dass wir eine Situation
haben die wirklich enorm hohe Ansprüche
setzt fein dann verhandelt ein Tag
länger aber dann ja nee das war nicht so
ganz leicht im im Verhältnis zum äh äh
zum sonstigen zum sonstigen Kalender
wissen Sie ich bin nicht Beteiligter bei
diesem Prozess gewesen mich stört aufen
gestand nur dass wir gerade Leute die
unter maximalen Stress stehen und die
ganz bestimmt aus meiner Sicht nicht
richtig gemacht haben dann sozusagen so
eine einer Stilkritik unterziehen von
uns glaube ich möchte mit den Dreien in
dieser Situation gerade niemand
getauscht haben und das würde ich immer
ganz gerne mit hinzufü ja Herr weil aber
bei 13% SPD in Umfragen Regierungspartei
und 23 22% AFD glaube ich geht es nicht
nur um stilragen sondern das ist ein
politisches Vakuum in das Leute stoßen
die nur dagegen sind und nichts anbieten
nichts das meine ich mit der AFD dagegen
zu sein ist mitlerweil ein politisches
programagennecht ist dagegen die AFD ist
dagegen die haben alle keine Idee wie es
weiter geht haben auch keine Erfahrung
nichts aber gerade das das Kommunikation
eine Rolle spielt das will ich gerne
auch sagen aber äh das vor allen Dingen
auch wir durch eine überzeugende Politik
aufwarten müssen durch
ein geschlossenes Auftreten das auch in
der Lage ist Vertrauen zu wecken das
scheint mir allerdings und das wäre für
mich die Bilanz des Jahres 2023 gewesen
noch mal das wesentlich wichtigere zu
sein